bumblebee
je m'appelle charlie white fans
j'ai 18 ans aujourd'hui en fait la
coccinelle est à vendre
elle est à toi
joyeux anniversaire
[Musique]
c'est pas vrai t'es quoi toi
et tu sais pas d'où ils sortent vraiment
pas vraiment parlé
waouh je t'explique
les gens peuvent être horrible avec ce
qu'ils ne comprennent pas
non la seule personne qui a droit de te
voir témoin ok c'est bon c'est bon là
c'est bon merci
une guerre fait rage sur notre planète
si on ne retrouve pas ce criminel notre
guerre deviendra la vôtre enfin
quelqu'un qui peut aider à une famille
oki mois
il faut punir une armée
j'ai pu voir ce que sont réellement ces
choses
bumblebee il n'y a qu'un moyen de mettre
un terme ce conflit
tu dois protéger la terre et ses
habitants
c'est le seul moyen
je suis là pour toi
avant donne pas
je vais faire tuer